[Musique]
le musée de la ville a deux aspects un
aspect qui porte d'ailleurs le label art
et histoire qui est donc toute
l'histoire du territoire depuis la
commanderie des des Templiers le le
musée de Port Royal enfin Port Royal
Deschamps l'évolution avec Versailles et
donc dans ce territoire c'était les
portes de du grand parc de de Versailles
et puis après il y a eu toute l'histoire
de l'arrivée de la SNCF en particulier
sur sur trap et la création des villes
des villes nouvelles et donc la création
de de 550 an enine donc là on retrace
toute l'histoire et en même temps avec
tout ce que l'on a pu récupérer sur les
plans et sur les maquettes pour voir
l'évolution de l'urbanisme et dans cette
partie historique on met en lien tous
les objets de vie on met toujours un
objet de vie qui est qui correspond à la
période montrée et
étudiée on peut consulter de la
documentation il y a des des petits
films qui peuvent être visionnés et
cetera ça c'est donc la partie
permanente de ce musée en parallèle il y
a une exposition temporaire qui change à
peu près tous les ans et qui elle est
liée à l'évolution des modes de vie dans
les modes de vie on voit aussi bien les
vêtements que les objets ménager que les
meubles et à partir de ce moment-là on
fait des expositions temporaires on a
une collection
énorme à ce musée que ça soit la partie
temporaire ou que ça soit la partie
permanente on met aussi des visites sur
S et on a aussi tout un fond
documentaire pour toutes les personnes
qui sont intéressées peuvent avoir
peuvent avoir accès on est plus
effectivement lié avec tout ce qui est
évolution des modes de vie donc
innovation que un vrai musée
historique